c'est une deux trois chèvres tuées
au même endroit, nous savons que c'est jitta que nous
n'avons pas encore compté, mais correctement, je la
tuerais si je garde toutes les chances mais
le problème avec Vegeta maintenant une fois qu'ils
entrent et qu'ils commencent à attraper des moutons
pour lesquels ils restent  environ trois quatre cinq
nuits et il n'y en a pas eu
qu'un qu'ils tuent environ trois quatre
cinq jusqu'à 38 ans était le plus à la fois ager
et ce que nous essayons de faire est de
trouver un moyen qu'elle puisse vivre en
harmonie avec  les gens et beaucoup d'agriculteurs
ont réalisé qu'ils devaient changer
ce n'est pas ce que nous voulions si les
guépards sanglants arrivent sur nos téléphones
que pouvons-nous faire pour survivre ou c'est vous les
pauvres garçons elle n'avait pas mentalement planifié le
nemi être sur la population africaine de Talavera p1 à
partir du mode d'alimentation, cela fera une
différence entre les Allen Prue aléatoires ou est la
difficulté L protégé
et
regarde les jours de salon chaque année pure
planète doula heureuse en modèle justice sur
le sommet de la pyramide ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
m.  les cylindres annuellement ont vraisemblablement rencontré une
importance en Afrique, je pense juste que
tout sur le guépard et
tout ce que j'ai appris est tellement
fascinant que vous savez de longues jambes un très
beau corps long et maigre comme un
gouvernail pour l'équilibre très élégant et avec
ça j'étais juste  fascinés par eux
leurs yeux leurs yeux regardent juste à travers
vous et au-delà de vous alors bien sûr les
trois sessions ont-elles Julia Robinson ouais
Kelly a risqué le
lv2 malgré ses nombreuses tessellations il y
avait environ une centaine de milliers de guépards
autour du 1900 donc nous avons moins que
je vais juste  disons qu'il reste 7 500 guépards dans le
monde et que le Botswana namibien en
a environ 1 500 chacun, nous avons donc près de
50% dans ces deux pays, de nombreux
animaux cellulaires différents à Audrey, vous voyez
le laissez-passer protégé général conféré le
laissez-passer Ligia que je pourrais reproduire tous les
Muto la famille tous présentés  près de l'
arbre
[Musique]
chacun parle d'Homère mais il pourrait être
plus d'un Tita parce qu'il n'attaquera pas
il paniquera il n'en mangera qu'un mais
dans ce cas, tous les trois vont manger de la
merde, je ne mangerai pas d'intestins, il n'y avait que
la viande autour de l'intestin, donc ça va l'
écorcher, vous pouvez voir où le corps
déchire la peau et ici donc et aussi
ici nous n'avons pas pris en compte  encore mais
correctement je le tuerais si jamais je
changeais d'
onami être de l'eau oculaire offensante à sa
famille de connaissances exceptionnelles
donne en fait un constituant clé - Paul avi qui
vend beaucoup de gens les familles en
Corée Contras attaquent un gars Johnny
incontrôlable Pascoe Aditi c'est une ferme
parmi un travail c'était en 1997, nous
avons eu dans une famille de quatre guépards la
mère de deux jeunes comme celui-ci et un
gros mâle et entre les quatre
sur une période de mois, ils ont attrapé 11 34
moutons 38 moutons la première nuit l'
en  l'automne quand les jeunes
guépards atteignent la taille de celui-ci c'est quand la
mère et le père commencent à
leur apprendre à chasser
et c'est alors qu'ils peuvent causer des pertes d'
environ 38 moutons une nuit le temps qu'ils
attrapent un bateau qu'ils leur montrent  un autre
un autre un autre ils ne
mangent que le dernier qu'ils attrapent
surtout au cours des 10 dernières années que les
pertes de teeta augmentent le
nombre de visites de bascule sur le
formulaire augmentait également
je veux dire vous vous prenez du Niger vous devez
donner  retour à la nature une autre fois, donc
si le guépard n'attrape qu'un ou
deux moutons, ce ne sont pas de grosses pertes, je veux dire que
le guépard doit manger si vous avez des pertes
de trente cinquante moutons par une famille de
guépards, c'est des pertes énormes d'
environ 6070
milliards de dollars  détective parent gay sur
une économique ici pleine famille israélienne
un pauvre beaucoup les récemment capturé
avec des valeur en espèces le train me fournit
Yossi protestation civile animal décodage
solution de mauvaise qualité circoncis au contraire
Makkah dans le périphérique ils forcent
différentes amandes ce que nous essayons de faire
est  pour trouver un moyen pour que les guépards puissent
vivre en harmonie avec les gens, la plupart des
guépards se trouvent en dehors des
zones protégées et c'est pourquoi nous devons w  Travail
avec les éleveurs si tôt que nous avons
lancé notre programme de chiens de garde du bétail
J'ai commencé cela en 1994 parce que d'
où je viens dans l'Oregon, nous avons en fait
eu beaucoup de conflits avec les coyotes et
les éleveurs de moutons et les chiens de garde du bétail
que nous utilisons maintenant  nos
bergers anatoliens ou chiens Kangal,
ils travaillent depuis environ cinq
mille ans pour protéger le bétail contre les
prédateurs et c'est donc là que nous avons bien pris parti pour
un chien de garde qui a en fait été
élevé et qui a évolué pour protéger le
bétail serait une chose très intéressante
à essayer est  l'épisode ressemble plus à un
Akuma sarah a implanté un lustre sur un
peut-être des présages et fait face à la
préoccupation saisonnière aujourd'hui lv un placide ou ils ont filmé
RP avec une autonomie de sabudana sur terre
pourriez-vous tirer donc ces gars-là, en gros,
c'est leur instinct naturel, ils se lient
à quelque chose  et ils apprennent à le
protéger, ils s'interposeront entre le bétail
et le prédateur, se tiendront debout et
aboieront très fort, c'est donc le premier
étape si le prédateur continue de venir après
le bétail, il le chassera,
il le chassera pour défendre son
bétail
maintenant, certains agriculteurs disent que cela peut
coûter cher, mais beaucoup d'agriculteurs disent que le
prix des soins pour ce chien est beaucoup
moins cher que le coût  de perdre un
mouton, ils pourraient perdre un de leurs moutons
pour environ 1 200 $ la plupart des agriculteurs voient
une réduction d'environ quatre-vingt à cent pour cent
de leurs pertes avec l'un de ces chiens
est-ce que l'oncle Tommy est un pauvre enfant Je pensais que
vous aviez vu ce jeune ours dire je ne
Je n'accepte pas tout ce que mes parents ont formé
mes grands-parents ont été agriculteurs Je suis l'une
des tribus connues pour être une
communauté agricole ou un
milieu agricole sûr cette autre tribu une fois que c'est
une jolie fille J'avais l'habitude de voir un danger
soit un danger pour ma vie
gingembre à  les trucs de la vie, je crois que
c'était que je n'étais pas présenté à deux
prédateurs et je ne savais pas comment les
gérer normalement, on envisagerait
soit de supprimer le plus qui était
comme en tirant ou en le pourchassant un  avec les
chiens et les lances et quoi que ce soit
depuis que je l'ai appris, il existe d'autres
moyens d'éloigner les prédateurs
de votre bétail et qui
introduisait alors un chien à votre mal
et je n'ai rien perdu d'un
prédateur jusqu'à présent  c'est alors seulement que j'ai
réalisé que nous pouvions tous vivre ensemble des
prédateurs
plus des choses de la vie plus le module humain de
la puissance du cerf peut-être le probablement du
transposon du véhicule compagnon Pascal en
quelque sorte il y a une solution et ils
s'en fichent parce que nous avons la famille de sortie la
différence ou  ils donnent notre cheval ou
même viennent à vous lorsque vous obtenez des agriculteurs qui
peuvent commencer à voir qu'ils pourraient y jouer un
rôle, leur attitude commence à changer
un peu et ils commencent à se rendre compte que
peut-être certaines de leurs
pratiques de gestion agricole pourraient changer peut-être les gens
dans le monde en fait  devraient comprendre
que les agriculteurs sont parmi nos meilleurs
défenseurs de l'environnement, mais ils doivent être
soutenus dans ce sens.
Papa Desi Ghee pouvoirs ou zones également
connues sous le nom de  soutien des éleveurs sur la
population sur l'animal de cet hôtel parisien
[Musique]
toi